I'm a natural Hagar so I only know of
the natural hair so and you know we have
to find textures we have to Kelly here
we have the the kinky ones it's tough
but it's good to have a you feel African
I've been whiten about natural hair
since 2005 for a particular magazine you
know at the beginning nobody even would
acknowledge they're like oh that's not
going to take off it's just a trend you
know no one's really gonna want to do
natural haste and then ten years later
so I literally eighty percent of our
clients are all-natural
years and years ago you to have natural
afro hair it will see it more as
political in terms of like oh my god I
need to go to this job interview my
hairs in his natural state they might
think I'm a mad person or they might
think I'm a little bit smoke too much
dope if I turned up so it was quite
political but if you look at the world
we live in now on the red carpet you've
got the pizza you've got women of color
they're embracing their natural hair